[Musik]
sebastian lege zeigt euch wie
hackfleisch mit hilfe von chemischen
gasen länger frisch bleibt und testet
welche auswirkungen das auf den
geschmack hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für das experiment hat produkte
entwickler lege seine werkstatt in einem
möglichst keimfreie umgebung verwandelt
denn bakterien aus der luft sind der
hauptgrund warum frische fleisch so
schnell verdirbt
[Musik]
was für eine schöne keimfrei muss wäre
aber um hackfleisch lange hübsch und
frisch zu halten reicht das noch lange
nicht aus dafür brauchen wir noch
richtig für gas
schutzgas lautet das zauberwort die
spezialmischung aus sauerstoff und
kohlendioxid schützt hackfleisch vor dem
grau werden und dem verderben wie in der
industrie entfernt sebastian erst einmal
mit einem vakuum ihr gerät die normale
luft auf der verpackung
schon jetzt wäre das hackfleisch länger
haltbar dochte seine rosa farbe würde
rasch verblassen deshalb dreht sebastian
gleich am graf an
jetzt kommt das passende
mischungsverhältnis aus sauerstoff und
kohlendioxid
beide gase kommen auch in normale
atemluft vor nur im falschen
missverhältnis los geht's mit dem
kohlendioxid langsam auf 10 jetzt
aufpassen
vorsichtig bläst sebastian das gas ein
bis die verpackung zu rund 30 prozent
mit kohlendioxid gefüllt ist das bremst
den einigungsprozess des fleisches
kohlendioxid hätten wir schon mal jetzt
kommt sauerstoff die wunderwaffe für
eine frische farbe denn eine spezielle
substanz im muskelfleisch bindet den
sauerstoff das heck wird schön rot 70
prozent sauerstoff gas sind dafür
optimal
fertig ist unsere schutzgas atmosphäre
das hackfleisch ist jetzt dem
kühlschrank rund fünf tage haltbar wie
wichtig eine intakte packung auch für
die optik ist zeigt dieser zeitraffer
beide packungen wurden mit gas befüllt
doch die linke ist undicht weil dort der
sauerstoff entweicht wird das fleisch
grau das rechts in der perfekten schutz
atmosphäre bleibt dagegen sogar über das
haltbarkeitsdatum hinaus rosarot doch
wirkt sich die schutzgas verpackung auf
den geschmack aus
das lassen wir im labor testen frisch
gekauftes hat gegen vier tage altes
verpacktes
beide proben werden bei exakt gleicher
temperatur gegart
dann folgt eine verkostung nach genauen
wissenschaftlichen standards
dazu zählt auch dass keiner der
testpersonen weiß welches produkt sie
ist
die geschulten sensorik erinnen bewerten
alle qualitätskriterien der hackfleisch
proben
in unserem fall sind das fahrrad
saftigkeit und aroma
in jeder kategorie werden punkte
vergeben als gesamtnote sind maximal
sechs punkte zu erreichen
das resultat nur 3,5 punkte für das
abgepackte hackfleisch das frische
bringt es auf 4,5 doch warum ist das so
das kann nur eine chemische analyse
klären
wieder vergleichen wir vor vier tagen
eingeschweißt ist mit frischem hug hat
der hohen sauerstoffgehalt in der
packung das fleisch verändert dann würde
die tests flüssigkeit rosa
und tatsächlich die färbung zeigt an
dass fleisch aus der verpackung ist
oxidiert der fettanteil schmeckt dadurch
leicht ranzig
wenn ich natürlich ein schlechteres
aroma und einen ranzigen geschmack in
meinem hackfleisch habe habe ich
natürlich eine deutlich schlechtere
qualität was geschmack und genuss angeht
und somit kann schutzgas dazu beitragen
dass das produkt qualitativ schlechter
ist ein dilemma für die hersteller soll
das fleisch gut aussehen oder gut
schmecken
der sauerstoffgehalt im gasgemisch
entscheidet die verbraucher erkennen nur
dass die ware mit schutzgas verpackt ist
nicht jedoch wie hoch der
sauerstoffanteil darin
[Musik]
wir haben bei fünf produkten den
sauerstoffgehalt messen lassen
gemischtes hackfleisch der vier
bekanntesten handelsketten auffällig der
sauerstoffgehalt ist in allen
verpackungen unterschiedlich
und es gibt bei spitzenreiter das
produkt von rewe mit über 60 prozent
sauerstoff und das bio hackfleisch von
lidl 70 prozent sauerstoff in der
schutzatmosphäre gut für den verkauf
schlecht für den genuss der fall gilt
auch abgepacktes hackfleisch besser
schnell verzehren
optisch immer noch rosa und wunderschön
aber geschmacklich leidet ganz schön die
qualität darunter schutzgas ist ein
nützlicher hygiene trick und weil auch
die hersteller die nebenwirkungen von
sauerstoff kennen wird er fast
ausschließlich bei produkten mit rotem
fleisch eingesetzt
denn nur hier entsteht der gewünschte
optische effekt worauf achtet ihr beim
kauf von hackfleisch und wie lange
bewahrt hieß auf sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips